[Musique]
aujourd'hui on se trouve à l'ENP
Business School à Saint-Quentin en
yeline c'est une école qui se spécialise
sur deux pôles de formation business et
marketing finance gestion et RH et cette
école elle forme des étudiants du bac +
2 au bac + 5 et elle met l'accent sur
l'expérience professionnelle en
proposant des cursus en alternance et
des formateurs issus du monde de
l'entreprise allez c'est parti on va
aller découvrir cette
[Musique]
école alors là on va aller rencontrer
Medy c'est un étudiant en business et
marketing et il va nous raconter un
petit peu son expérience ici à l'école
bonjour m bonjour ça va ça va et vous
merci ça va je vous dérange pas trop non
du tout je venais de finir génial B vous
êtes sur quoi là alors là je suis en
train de finaliser un travail sur le
lead nerturing le lead nerturing c'est
ça tout à faitis pas du tout c'est un
cours de marketing digital ok donc voilà
donc comme moi je fais un Bachelor
responsable commercial
marketing il y a des cours de marketing
digital le formateur nous a envoyé six
vidéos à regarder donc en les visionnant
on a fait des
de de ces vidéos là et donc du coup on
les a présenté en PowerPoint pour mieux
expliquer et surtout expliquer avec nos
mots à nos camarades c'est ça aussi qui
est bien c'est pour faciliter la
compréhension c'est ça tout à fait comme
on a pratiquement une moyenne d'âge
pareil donc je vais mieux expliquer à
mes camarades que un formateur par
exemple et ça nous force aussi à
travailler et à écouter le camarade
génial B va écoutez on va vous suivre
dans votre présentation allez c'est
parti
[Musique]
14h05 c'est l'heure pour Medy de
réaliser sa présentation alors moi je me
suis concentré sur la
partie des grandes étapes du
nuring très
[Musique]
intéressant rencontrons maintenant
Tiffanie chargée des relations entrepris
c'est elle qui accompagne les étudiants
dans leur recherche d'alternance a
d'ailleurs été étudiante à laen suup et
connaît donc très bien les enjeux de
l'école aujourd'hui 95 % de ces
étudiants sont en contrat c'est vraiment
important pour moi aujourd'hui l'école
nensu pourquoi parce que j'ai été
justement la personne qui a pu
bénéficier de ce suivi de cette
accompagnement aussi bien pédagogique
que dans la su le suivi de mon
alternance et également j'ai pu voir les
différentes problématiques qu'il
pouvaient y avoir à la recherche d'une
alternance à l'accompagnement des
tuteurs à l'accompagnement des
entreprises donc c'est extrêmement
important aujourd'hui ce savoirfire et
c'est ce qui fait aussi l'identité de
notre groupe aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
ce suivi cet accompagnement aussi bien
des étudiants mais également des
entreprises ouis donc en fait c'est du
vécu ce que vous nous racontez
exactement c'est du vécu et puis
justement on on on on est vraiment
porteur de l'alternance au sein de notre
école mais et même également au sein de
nos locaux puisque nous avons dans tous
les services des alternants issus de nos
formations pourquoi parce que on sait
que c'est ce qu'il faut il faut former
nos jeunes de demain pour qu'ils
puissent rentrer sur le marché du
travail avec toutes les armes possibles
aujourd'hui les entreprises sentent que
les étudiants d'up ont déjà de
l'expérience et qui sont viables sur le
marché effectivement on a un taux
d'embauche pour postebac+ 5 qui est
quand même extrêmement intéressant et
j'irai même plus loin on a aussi des
partenaires sur le 50 an en Eveline qui
nous demande de venir rencontrer nos bac
plus 5 en vue justement de les embaucher
même si l'alternance n'était pas chez
eux à la base bien merci de nous avoir
partagé votre expérience mais aussi
votre rôle dans cette école Tiffanie c
un vrai plaisir merci merci beaucoup
et on termine notre visite avec Marie
agès Amabile chargée des relations
extérieure elle est en charge notamment
des questions sociales et
environnementales une des priorités de
l'école bonjour Marie Agnès bonjour
bienvenue merci on m'a dit que je
pouvais vous trouver ici qu'est-ce que
vous êtes en train de faire alors là on
est en train de travailler tout toute
notre campagne d'affichage on a la
chance avoir un territoire qui est très
actif et l'objectif c'est de pouvoir
valoriser toutes les actions qui sont
faites auprès des étudiants donc là par
exemple on valorise le covoiturage on
travaille aussi sur l'accès au logement
l'accès aux soins et cetera et et l'idée
c'est de pouvoir faire en sorte
d'accompagner les étudiants dans toutes
les étapes de leur quotidien et j'ai vu
que vous étiez aussi très sensible aux
question environnementale est-ce que
c'est vous qui êtes à l'origine du
carton de tri qu'on voit en bas oui
c'est grâce au comité environnemental de
l'école que on a pu mettre ses actions
en place en fait on a la chance de
pouvoir faire le tri de manière
impactante socialement et
environmentalement parlant et donc on
travaille avec une association qui
finance la recherche contre certaines
maladies en recyclant des matériaux de
bureau usagers je peux vous montrer si
vous voulez ben génial écoutez je vais
vous
[Musique]
suivre
alors nous voici donc comme vous le
voyez on a toutes les tous les stylos et
les feutres usagés qui sont mis dans ces
cartons on en a mis un peu partout dans
l'école et donc ces stylos et ces
feutres sont envoyés à l'association ose
on a bien fait attention à mettre une
affiche pour sensibiliser aussi à
l'action sociale et puis l'idée c'est
qu'on puisse récolter un maximum de de
déchets pour pouvoir les envoyer et dès
que le carton sera rempli ce sera B et
donc du coup c'est tous les étudiants le
personnel tout le monde est concerné par
l'action oui exactement on a à la fois
les collaborateurs les formateurs et les
étudiants et donc ça permet aussi de
rassembler tout le monde pour une cause
et c'est quelque chose qui fonctionne
bien j'ai l'impression ouais ouais ouais
ça fonctionne hyper bien on est très
content ça fait 2 mois qu'on qu'on a mis
ça en place et vous pouvez voir qu'il y
a déjà pas mal de stylos
usager et c'est ainsi que s'achève notre
visite à lensup Business School une
école de commerce qui met l'accent sur
l'expérience professionnelle et qui est
également sensible aux questions
sociales et environnementales j'espère
que vous avez apprécié la visite et je
vous dis à bientôt pour un prochain
épisode de la chronique
[Musique]
éducation